this is building serious PEC shoulder
and tricep strength it's also a huge
Core workout as you'll need to stabilize
your midsection to be able to transfer
the strength into the ground the best
part is its anti- rotation that means
you're combating gravity as it attempts
to twist your unsupported side down to
the ground we're building more strength
in the rotational plane then and this is
some of the most functional strength
there is whether you're rying pushing
pulling throwing or punching to do the
perfect one-armed push-up you're going
to spread your legs but not too wide
which makes it easier push yourself back
up once your nose touches or nearly
touches the floor push all the way
through so that you're extending your
arm and protracting your scapula at the
top you might even hear your back crack
which is a great
feeling if you can't do a one-armed
push-up Place one hand on a raised
object and then move more of your weight
to the other hand you can this way
assist yourself and get a nice deep
stretch for the pecs which is a great
stimulus